the Tesla Model Y is filled with some
great pros and cons and most of the time
a lot of the cons come to the surface
however today we're going to be talking
about all of these cons that can be
debunked and actually aren't a problem
for us whatsoever
first of all build quality is
significantly better than anybody has
previously stated before our model y
came out of the Shanghai Factory which
to be fair there have been positive
reviews compared to those out of the
framework Factory and also the factory
out in Europe currently the Shanghai
Factory is producing the most units
compared to any other Factory so it is
very efficient at what it does however
that doesn't take away or discourage
anything from the actual build quality
I've owned a few luxury cars in my life
and every single one of them squeaked
rattled or had some sort of annoying
noise within the cabin when driving for
the first time my life I can genuinely
say that the Tesla Model y has no
squeaks no rattles no absolutely
annoying little buzzing sounds anywhere
when you're driving so from an everyday
consumer point of view this is by far
one of the best things however when you
actually look at the build quality
overall of the car it was phenomenal
when we picked up the model y there was
no panel gaps no scratches absolutely
nothing it was in near perfect condition
like I mentioned in previous videos
there was a couple little hiccups here
and there so for example the seats
themselves were quite a little bit Dusty
inside and there was a small Mark or two
on the rear seats from the seat belts
overall the steering wheel was perfect
all the alignment of the panels were
perfect there wasn't any discoloration
outside of the norm from the panels and
the paints all was acceptable and with
intolerances for my personal opinion
generally speaking about the whole car
there was absolutely no concerns about
build quality from the Shanghai Factory
now let's move on to suspension first of
all suspension was one of the items that
was brought up in almost every single
video when the model white was released
in Australia everybody commented that it
was incredibly firm it was incredibly
hard and it wasn't a comfortable ride
whatsoever however what we found is
actually that is very much so untrue yes
it is a little bit harder than most cars
in that Medium SUV range however that is
not saying or taking anything away from
the actual suspension package the
suspension is very very good and what
you get used to very quickly is when
you're driving the Tesla Model y it
feels like a sports car rather than your
standard medium-sized SUV so you get
used to the harder suspension you get
used to the like ride height you get
used to the tight Corners it's actually
very very enjoyable now personally I do
like sports cars I have always had low
cars in my entire life so I'm not taking
anything away from the fact that other
cars have better suspension absolutely
they do but I don't think think that
suspension should be an issue I knew
when we were purchasing the model why
everybody was talking about suspension
being bad and it was a point that almost
put us off buying the model y or at
least delaying it till we could test
drive it a few months later down the
track thankfully we bit the bullet
pre-ordered the vehicle and we've been
happy ever since there is nothing to be
concerned about about suspension another
fun fact that keeps coming up is the
actual glass
so the glass of the Tesla Model Y is
obviously expansive it is significantly
more than most other cars on the road
you have that full panoramic sunroof you
have all of your other windows as
standard as well so most of your cabin
is typically glass in this vehicle what
people don't realize is they're
extremely tinted so the roof for example
you can barely even see out of it on a
very cloudy day because it is nearly
pitch black you can see out of it on a
sunny day it is beautiful but it is not
like your typical sunroof that just
clear glass the rear window and the rear
passenger windows are all extremely
tinted as well it is only the front two
drivers windows and the windshield that
aren't sensored but they are UV
protected this is also the first vehicle
I haven't had to go out and purchase
additional UV protection on because
there has been no issues whatsoever now
I understand that people are also
worried about the cabin getting
extremely hot and yes if you turn your
cabin over heat protection off it
absolutely will be stinking hot inside
cabin if you live in a hot climate now
we live in Australia so it's relatively
hot here but also it does get cooler in
the Winter's months so you have a bit of
a balance overall the cabin over heat
protection tends to kick in pretty
quickly I've got mine set to 38 degrees
and it's not too uncomfortable getting
in the car after a hot day I do believe
if I parked it outside in the direct sun
for a very prolonged period of time it
would be extremely hot but so is every
other car so I don't think that the
sunroof in itself causes that car to
overheat too much as long as you have
your overheat protection on now on a
side note to this huge panoramic sunroof
it is actually covered on our insurance
policy under window and glass protection
so for Rock drop the tree fell on it
Whatever Happened it's protected under
its own insurance policy separate to the
main vehicle insurance policy I do
recommend you check this with your
insurance company ours is only a very
small fee if it ever does crack or break
another huge elephant in the room is the
white seats now the white seats are
beautiful they make the car what it is
and so many people get deterred by white
seats everybody we're told that we were
getting white seats their immediate
reaction was you're crazy however so far
so good the white seats are incredibly
easy to keep clean they don't stain and
generally speaking there is no issues
with them so why do people complain
about white seeds well honestly I
believe people are complaining about the
white seeds because they're not keeping
their car clean they're not looking
after their vehicles and if we let go of
the car and just completely trash the
seats then absolutely even any other
fabric seat or any other leather seat
would get completely trashed if you just
left it alone for prolonged period of
time however when you look after it you
simply just have to use a baby wipe
that's predominantly water on them once
a week and you're good to go if it does
get a little bit stained for whatever
reason you can use pure Castile soap on
the top of it which is basically a very
gentle non-detergent soap they can clean
most of the stains that are stuck I have
spoken to Tesla about getting rid of the
stains on the seats themselves and they
said bring it in and they'll clean the
seeds with a product that they have in
their showroom last but not least Tesla
recently introduced a new feature that
basically took away one of your greatest
Assets in the car after eight years of
ownership you are going to have to pay
for basic connectivity which is your
navigation now you use this almost all
day every day and it automatically syncs
with your calendar so it really gets you
into the habit of using this navigation
which also helps the computer understand
how much battery you're going to have
left personally speaking eight years is
a very long time and approximately the
length of time I'm planning on keeping
this vehicle for have a win that eight
years it does turn around I'm expecting
it to only be about five to ten dollars
a month in line with that premium
connectivity if not even cheaper so this
is slightly a con however the premium
connectivity that they offer you free
for the first 30 days to try to get you
hooked in isn't required whatsoever in
my opinion it isn't often that you're
really going to need to use Spotify or
that you're going to want to watch
Netflix on the actual Tesla or that you
need any of those other features it is
an amazing option absolutely but you can
always hotspot your phone to use some of
these features so overall I don't think
this feature is needed I think it's just
an excessive waste of money anyway
that's all for me today guys thank you
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
the video if you did make sure you check
out the playlist inside of me for more
great Tesla content if you loved the
video make sure you hit that subscribe
button down below but like always I'll
see you next Monday